♪ ♪
BEFORE WORK -- >> Greg: A NEW
STUDY OF MILLENNIALS FOUND ONE-T
STUDY OF MILLENNIALS FOUND ONE-I
STUDY OF MILLENNIALS FOUND ONE-D
BELIEVE THEIR LIVES ARE MORE
STRESSFUL THAN THE AVERAGE
PERSON IN 60% FEEL LIFE IS MORE
STRESSFUL THAN EVER BEFORE.
OKAY.
TO HOLD THOSE OPINIONS, YOU
CANNOT HAVE BEEN ALIVE OR
COGNIZANT DURING WORLD WARS,
TERROR ATTACKS, CRIME WAVES,
KILLER DISEASES, WHEN
JIMMY CARTER WAS PRESIDENT, THE
CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS, OR WHEN
DINOSAURS WALKED THE EARTH.
HOW ELSE CAN YOU BELIEVE LIVING
THE MOST PROSPEROUS PEACEFUL
TIME IN EXISTENCE, THE TRUMP
ERA, IS STRESSFUL.
YOU WANT STRESSFUL, LOOK UP 1942
OR DON KNOTS.
I THINK YOUR LIFE -- SEEKING
YOUR LIFE IS MORE STRESSFUL IS
SIMPLY HUMAN NATURE.
WE ALL FIND OUR OWN HANGNAIL
MORE URGENT THAN MALARIA.
THERE ARE WORST STRESSORS.
HERE ARE THREE.
THIS GUIDE MIGHT BE PRESIDENT.
THIS COULD BE YOUR BOSS.
THIS COULD BE YOU.
THANK GOD YOU DON'T WAKE UP TO
THIS EVERY MORNING.
OR LOOKING LIKE THIS.
OR LAUGHING LIKE THIS.
TOP DAILY STRESSES INCLUDED A
DAMAGED PHONE SCREEN AND
IGNORING SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS.
SO LIFE IS GOOD.
THAT'S NOT A GAS CRISIS OR
STAG-FLATION.
NO ONE REMEMBERS THAT.
LOSING A WALLET CAME IN FIRST.
SECOND WAS AN ARGUMENT WITH YOUR
PARTNER.
EVEN IN THIS NEW WORLD, NO
MATTER HOW GREAT YOUR DAY IS, IT
GOES TO HELL WHEN YOU KNOW WHO
ISN'T SPEAKING TO YOU.
WE HAVE SOMETHING IN COMMON WITH
THEIR PARENTS AND THEIR PARENTS
AND THEIR PARENTS.
A COLD SHOULDER HURTS MORE THAN
ZERO LIKES.
THAT MADE ME HAPPY, DANA.
PEOPLE STILL GET UPSET ABOUT
HUMAN INTERACTION.
>> Dana: YES.
THAT HAPPENED TO PETER AND ME A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
HE WOKE UP ON THE WRONG SIDE OF
THE BED.
>> Greg: I HATE THAT.
>> Dana: HE WAS IN A BAD MOOD
AND HE YELLED AT JASPER.
>> Jesse: WOW.
>> Dana: TOLD HIM TO GET OUT
OF THE WAY IN BED.
HE SAID HOW CAN YOU DO THAT?
I'M SORRY, PETER, THAT I'M
TELLING THE STORY.
HE STARTED MOCKING ME.
HE WAS LIKE OH, JASPER, WHY
DON'T YOU MOVE ACROSS THE BED.
I DIDN'T SPEAK TO HIM FOR FOUR
HOURS.
>> Jesse: I THOUGHT THE
CONWAYS HAD A PROBLEM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: THE EQUIVALENT OF THE
CONWAYS WOULD BE PETER GOING TO
SOME OTHER NETWORK AND TRASHING
JASPER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: LIKE ANIMAL PLANET.
>> Greg: YOU ARE SAYING THAT
JASPER IS THE GREATEST AND PETER
IS ON ANIMAL PLANET.
>> Dana: WE MADE UP.
>> Greg: EMILY, I GUESS
TECHNICALLY YOU'RE MILLENNIAL.
>> Emily: I'M NOT.
I WAS BORN IN THE '70s.
>> Greg: YOU'RE GOING TO BE 50
THIS MARCH?
>> Emily: CLOSE TO IT.
I FEEL LIKE THAT EVER ONE THING
THEY ARE AFRAID OF IS
DISCONNECTION BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE REAL CONNECTIONS ON THE
OUTSIDE AND ALSO I WENT TO A
PARTY AND THERE WERE A BUNCH OF
INFLUENCERS THERE AND I WAS LIKE
INTERESTING, WHATEVER.
THEY WERE ALL CHILDREN.
NONE OF THEM KNEW HOW TO SPEAK.
NONE OF THEM KNEW HOW TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION.
I WAS HORRIFIED.
I LEFT EARLY.
IT WAS HORRIBLE.
I HAVE A GOOD IDEA FOR A REALITY
SHOW.
MILLENNIALS VERSUS EVERYONE
ELSE.
YOU HAVE TO NAVIGATE LIFE AND
THEY CAN USE THEIR DEVICES.
THEY HAVE TO USE     ASK FOR DIR
THEY HAVE TO USE     ASK FOR DIC
THEY HAVE TO USE     ASK FOR DII
THEY HAVE TO USE     ASK FOR DIN
THEY HAVE TO USE     ASK FOR DIS
THEY HAVE TO USE     ASK FOR DI.
THEY WILL NOT SUCCEED.
>> Jesse: I LIKE HOUSE SHE
SAYS -- HOW SHE SAYS "AND ALSO."
>> Greg: JUAN, YOU ARE
DIVORCED FROM TECHNOLOGY.
>> Juan: I'M NOT DIVORCED.
I HAVE TWO CELL PHONES.
I EVEN READ BOOKS ON AN iPAD.
TOOK ME A LONG TIME BECAUSE I
LIKE HARDCOVERS.
>> Greg: WHAT IS YOUR DAILY
STRESS?
>> Juan: I CAN NAME IT.
[LAUGHTER]
WHEN YOUNG PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
THIS, I THINK IT TIES INTO
LONELINESS, SENSE OF BEING
SEPARATE, JEALOUS OF OTHER
PEOPLE.
BECAUSE OTHER PEOPLE HAVE
THINGS.
THEY ARE ON A GREAT TRIP AND THE
LIKE.
THE ALIENATION TO ME IS A BIG
FACTOR, AND I SEE IT IN SUICIDE
NUMBERS AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE.
IT'S OFTEN CITED AS BECAUSE THEY
WERE BEING BULLIED AND IT'S
COMING THROUGH THAT KIND OF
MEDIA.
TO ME, WE ARE LIVING THROUGH
CHANGING TIMES.
THEY ARE THE TIP OF THE SPHERE
IN TERMS OF HAVING BEEN
INFLUENCED AND GROWING UP WITH
THIS.
EVERYTHING FROM PORNOGRAPHY TO
MUSIC IS DIFFERENT.
>> Greg: WE HAVE SAID
TECHNOLOGY IS WAY AHEAD OF
HUMANITY.
JESSE, ONE OF THESE STRESSORS
WAS "ENGINE LIGHT GOES ON" IN
CAR.
>> Jesse: IT IS STRESSFUL.
HAPPENED TO ME.
NOT A PRETTY PICTURE.
100 YEARS AGO, THEY DIDN'T HAVE
A WORD FOR STRESS.
IT WAS CALLED LIFE.
HE WOKE UP, WENT TO WORK, WENT
TO WAR, CAME HOME, HAD A DRINK,
WENT TO BED.
THE LAST CENTURY, THERE WAS A
DRAFT.
PEOPLE HAD THEIR HEADS CRACKED
OPEN PROTESTING CIVIL RIGHTS.
THEY HAD KIDS DYING BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THE RIGHT MEDICINE
AND OUR KIDS ARE UPSET BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT GETTING LIKES.
I WAS READING
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" MAGAZINE
AND THERE WAS A GREAT QUOTE THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE.
I BLAME THE PARENTS.
IT'S HIS PARENTS SHOULD PREPARE
THEIR KIDS FOR THE ROAD, NOT THE
ROAD FOR THE KID.
THAT'S BECAUSE YOU CAUGHT ALL
THESE KIDS BECAUSE I NEVER
UNCOMFORTABLE IN WHATEVER THEY
FACED ADVERSITY, THEY MELT DOWN.
THAT'S WHY MY PARENTS SENT ME TO
OUTDOOR WILDERNESS SURVIVAL
SCHOOLS TO MAKE ME SO
UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> Greg: THEY WERE TRYING TO
KILL YOU.
>> Jesse: THEY JUST WANTED ME
TO SUFFER.
>> Dana: I LOVE THE STORY,
WHEN YOU GOT BLISTERS ON YOUR
FEET.
>> Jesse: ON MY FACE.
I HAD ZINC OXIDE ALL OVER MY
FACE BECAUSE MY FACE PEELED OFF.
>> Emily: FROM THE SUN?
[LAUGHTER]